welcome to the recruitment right across
the podcast my name is Hisham azuz and
today I'm joined by Lloyd Stokes who is
the founder of a recruitment business
called Talent digital and they are a
tech and digital sales and marketing
agency based in the lovely Ashford Kent
welcome to the podcast Lloyd Thank You
thanks for joining me I think and after
we got introduced by April he's also
been on the podcast at me so looking
forward to this one though so we just
had a good chart chat before we started
but as I was saying where I always like
to start in this podcast is how you go
into recruitment and we'll sort of then
I have you been a recruitment business
owner we'll have a real good
conversation around your journey so far
when your own recruiting agency but how
did you get into recruitment Lloyd's Day
it's tougher so as I was saying before
we started left school went to uni for a
year and had about 15 jobs up until I
was about 23 including being a postman
would agree that you do business in
marketing the only reason asked that the
last couple of episodes there and like
prob they're being property recruiters
and they both did philosophy degrees
really then I've ended up in recruitment
for like 5-10 years so just interested
there but yeah I did one year the
business and marketing degree and the
only thing that I can remember is that
there's an added study we did a study of
JFK and the assassination and that was
and that was amazing and then after you
are left and then I worked at Asda yeah
loads of different jobs yeah yeah
checkered past anyway and then I came to
London I got a job in sales working for
a comical video arts who were a video
training company founded by John Cleese
and was there for about 18 months and I
just wasn't quite sure where I was going
selling to and no idea really about
recruitment or the market in London at
all so went to go meet a recruitment
agency called
syrtis sales at the time they know
syrtis recruitment here in Covent Garden
got pitched on about five different
sales roles and at the ends like some
guy came in and said
if you thought about recruitment and I
was like nope not at all um so talked
about it for a bit sounded pretty
interesting good group of guys went back
for a second interview talk to the sales
director about rugby for about an hour
and then for 15 minutes talked about the
job and they got offered the job so that
was back in 2007 2007 see yes you've
been in recruitment for over a decade
now not entirely no oh yeah no sorry yes
because you see so you had Locker what
is it like a to freest in initially at
that business yeah and then he left and
then I saw in your LinkedIn profile she
left there and then what did you say
McCrimmon or not yes so I sorted two
years at syrtis yeah first year 2007
yeah
smashed it but absolutely realistic yeah
first year like I loved it
2008 credit crunch literally just
decimated well I didn't definitely the
business the business was still running
but it just went from being yeah big
billing to suddenly no one was hiring it
was incredibly hard client that I was
recruiting for at the time approached me
about a role and I just completely left
recruitment for 18 months really yeah
I'm got approached after 18 months
wasn't quite sure ever what I was doing
was quite right got approached by the
founders of syrtis again yeah he were
like look we've written through it we're
doing well we've hired some good people
we don't read have much experience would
you be interested in coming back in more
of a kind of billing managers role so
yeah then I went back went back in 2011
okay so no 2010 2010 in and then how
long was you there for that period four
years yeah yeah four years so overall
you worked that business for life six
years six years in tow yeah and then
after that you when did you go internal
no nice to that because there was
another role before you start your own
business right so for years that service
was just not sure of really career-wise
where I wanted to go yeah was running
their London office was like 22
consultants we're doing well but I just
didn't know where ever I really wanted
to be in recruitment long term or what
kind of what I felt like was good
recruitment or what you know what I
wasn't sure about the industries
I left and had about three months out
and then joined a software company in a
sales management role yeah I was there
for a year and literally I think within
about a month of joining that business I
just thought it's just just wrong it's
not for you yeah just there's something
not right about this isn't at the time
like it took me some time to realize but
what was really as I spent 10 years
commuting to London and I throw I master
it from Ashford yeah so lived in Ashford
I lived in London for a year and loved
it but born and bred in Ashford that's
where kind of family friends you know
everything is so and still is and yeah
it just was I don't know I just I just
couldn't see myself spending the next
like 30 years yeah yeah you struggle to
sort of visualize yourself there yeah
that's a couple years so to commit to
something yeah I just I literally get
the chain to work in the morning and see
all of these miserable people in the
jail in there like forties and fifties
and I'm thinking to myself I can't do
this for the rest of my life so then I'm
thinking okay I need to do something
which is nearer to home I thought about
the idea of doing my own business but
not really seriously yeah and I
literally just one day was like I'm
doing it I'm just gonna do it and just
to happens I'm getting out of London and
how'd you do at that point
how old was you at that point so it's
four years ago so I was 34 Wow okay yeah
that's interesting that you've been an
interesting journey
yeah of you designs of starting your own
business I think I mean probably fair to
say that you had probably classes about
job poppy candidates for years yeah
probably so they might not sure if I'd
call me
main driver then or one of the main
drivers was you want to work from home
and then you wasn't sure not work from
home so but what close time yeah but no
work from home to begin with yes I just
want to get a bit more balance playing
in life that was it that's one of the
main drivers well yeah yeah no massively
it was yeah my wife and I were trying
for a family and it was like if we're
gonna have children am I gonna be like
getting on a train at 6 o'clock in the
morning and not getting home to work I'm
not gonna see them and then at the
weekend I'm gonna be neck
so was there a particular moment then it
seems like you sort of built up to the
point of like yeah I've seen these
people I don't want to be that person in
10 15 20 years you'll sort of realized
what your priorities are what's
important to you and yeah was there a
bit of a moment way like you know well
actually why not less let's see if I can
do my own thing or was it just a buildup
of just realizing more actually a nor
honestly I think at first it was like a
buildup of just I don't want to do this
I'm fed up with this yeah and as I what
can I do and and I thought about it
loosely before and I thought I could do
that and and selling the software which
I thought I'd really enjoy and running
like that I realized that I really loved
recruitment I really really enjoyed the
process I enjoyed the challenges I made
I actually enjoyed everything about
recruitment
I enjoy the diversity of it rather than
just selling the same product yeah yeah
yeah yeah just people like that like
huge interaction mmm and I was good at
it no it was the it was the stuff that
came with that when you worked in London
they sort of probably encourage you to
try other things and work out of
businesses but it took you a little
while to it as well actually as probably
commuting everything else that comes
with it yeah I think so I think it just
like yeah I uh I was 2,500 going to
recruitment I'm always astounded by
these like 20 20 year olds or 21 year
olds you like come in and like spend
like seven or eight years in one
business because I'm just like it took
me quite a while to really understand
what I was good at and what I enjoyed
and I think I think yes it takes
experimentation and trying different
things right yeah which massively helps
that okay interest in so decide to start
your own business so the first year then
yeah was it just you or just to sort of
frame that up because obviously there's
I didn't say in the intro but there's
five of you now yeah the way you aren't
a currently is the five of you you've
been on a bit of a journey in terms of
the market that you serve and focus on I
know as you said before we started in
the process of going through a bit of a
rebrand and change your name but when
let's just sort of go to the beginning
like how yeah so what what did the first
year that like and was it this year yeah
was it yeah so I think if you were
setting up a recruitment business I did
it in the worst possible way
why
so at 18 months my last 18 months at
Sirtis I was running an office I didn't
have any clients didn't know billing
nothing at all actually managing
managers and so all of my relationships
have gone and then I did a year working
in a different sector Wow so when I set
up by myself it was literally in the
study at home with a computer what
having not recruited nothing for two and
half years no relationships no contacts
whether you start then I was like [ __ ]
I've written this business plan why did
you write business plan next year
because I think I love yeah I kind of
spoke to a couple of people where it's
like yeah how much of a business plan
should I have like I think someone said
recently I can't remember who it is I'm
not sure if I've shared the podcast yet
but and they said sort of obviously
plans important but like the actual
purpose is the the key part really like
if you've got a plan that's great which
hopefully should be able to be flexible
with it but for me if I think Tim said
actually yeah so if he was to go back
his like to really nail that down
because obviously he started at home and
things like that it's a similar journey
but where did you where did you yeah a
lot what what did the business plan what
was involved that because as you just
said so I no idea how to write a
business plan my wife was a business
studies teacher a levels business
teacher and she was like fully
supportive of just the whole idea of
getting more balanced but she said to me
if you're going to do it then you've got
a right business plan because obviously
he you're walking away from being an
employee paid job we've got mortgage and
stuff like that to do so I need to know
that you've thought about this long and
hard and it brings something that you've
just exactly that yeah a whim and I'm 34
years old at that time so I can't just
like - yeah yeah you've got
responsibilities so yeah I mean she
actually helped me quite a lot because
she knew what a business plan should
incorporate mmm so we did we did it
together but fundamentally when it comes
down to it on day one you you're back
just as a recruiter you know you can
have a plan and the intention and we
mapped out growth and hiring and
costs and those kind of means but that
changes dramatically stuff that you know
things that you think are going to cost
you a lot sometimes don't cost you as
much and vice versa so it's good to have
that it's good to have it but I think
the purpose or the intention of why
you're done of why you really want to do
it I was going to a business plan is not
going to get you up in the morning and
drive you on what like that that's about
that's having a purpose that's having an
intention to want to try and create
something so what was your intention and
at that point and has it evolved
yeah like evolved that changed
completely my intention at the time was
to get back to doing something that I
enjoyed to get more control and balance
in my life and to test out wherever I
was any good working for myself and
wherever actually enjoyed it you know
number four yeah yeah like outside of
anything else that that yeah that enough
there's a real honest sort of thing -
yeah I think that's fair yeah I mean I
listen to a lot of other people's
podcast and they'll talk yeah other
founders who talk about you know I had
like a massive plan and I was gonna nail
this this this that wasn't what I was
looking to do at first it was just kind
of make this work yes sure can I do I
want yeah what the time we were just I
was just working with digital brands and
while trying to work with digital brands
and I wanted to work them cuz I thought
there's it was cool and interesting and
I met some really interesting people on
that journey but fundamentally it was I
want to do something work wise that i
enjoy and have control over and have
balance that was that was it I really
like that so then the actual
practicalities then like what you did in
those first couple of months then was it
as literally as so yeah so how do you
decide in the market man so did you go
back to the market that you served in
your recruitment days or yes when I my
whole time syrtis was sales recruitment
generically and then we decide to like
silo that down into certain sectors yeah
and then I launched their digital part
their business which kind of got my
interest going around and kind of what
digital was and and started working with
some clients in that space so when it
came to then setting up the business
myself
it just makes complete sense
whilst I didn't necessarily have lots of
clients to bring over I I did know he
bit about them yeah I didn't know people
yes Neil knew a bit about this sector
and similarity I'm saying yeah I mean I
literally pick up the phone yeah yeah
yeah what I did first was I went through
my LinkedIn connections
I went through every single first
connection yeah and I looked at the
people in the way who do I actually
genuinely have a connection with yeah
and who could I pick up the phone to and
just see if they like can help me how
many how many people fell into that
category would you say when you get that
was that as many as you think
no yeah not as many as you think like
interest in but it did not as many G for
know 20 25 yeah it's mad right no no yes
like their news NASA is interesting
because like we all as recruiters spend
all down this platform like I'd never
[ __ ] loads of people you see that number
going yeah and you forget and then it's
like okay push comes to shove you out of
this Network were actually helped me and
I think it's interesting that but do you
know the thing that I really realized
and I realized now more than ever in the
last two years because I've really
focused on it is up until that point I
hadn't worked in environments or even
personally placed like massive emphasis
on building relationships marker I've
recruited and worked on roles and made
placements but the deep relationships
did which are more than just like I've
got a CV do you want to see that person
yeah there weren't that many in
cultivate and I didn't I didn't why why
did why why is that exactly is that a
fact yeah why didn't why didn't you did
that um I think that I worked in an
environment where we were very
fast-paced and quite number of metric
focused business and that maybe didn't
have as much time to do that but I also
think I I just didn't place enough
importance on I didn't I didn't it was
like I've got a client they've got some
roles and I need to fill them and I
think also when I got into recruitment
and back in 2007 there's a great market
just before the credit crunch she's an
amazing mom yes it's just like client
five
yeah you know I did I did almost 200
grand in my first year Cheers
[Music]
yes and then plead it fair enough so
yeah oh she's more of a few different
factors but yeah that's interesting so
first six months then like when did you
do your first deal yeah Liz she just
before Christmas so three and a half
months really yeah
Charlotte price climb online yes
junior-junior marketing sales role and
you know what that the really
interesting thing about that is I don't
my reference isn't on here climb on
lines of digital marketing agency
founded by a guy called mark right yeah
how's like I'm promoting his business
home he won the apprentice back in 2014
okay and I kind of know okay is it what
is he not it's not South African was
Australian Australian that's yeah yeah
so I know hearing about I met him once
because we worked for the same company
at different point I literally messaged
him on LinkedIn and I was number saying
I'll just set up like would you help me
and he would literally came back to me
straight away yeah yeah that's have a
call and he was like I'd love to help
you screwed me on the fees but I can
screw you on the fees because I move
your first client and I was like yeah
that's what can we do so it's amazing
digital marketing agency perfect let's
just talk about those first couple of
months yes I can imagine someone
listening right now or someone earlier
on that journey thinking about standing
and recruitment business or or going for
that the moment that that's obviously
one of the biggest fears right like am I
gonna am I gonna be able to make
placements yeah I've been work for
someone for a while yeah am I gonna be
able to my placement so those first
couple of months like how how did you
get through those months on essentially
blanking I'm not making any money like
did you did you have in your head the
right I'm gonna give myself at least six
months at this before I'm like you know
what maybe this isn't for me or
someone's you know I mean so like how
did you how did you get through those
first couple of months then secure slow
so yeah so I had six months he's
actually that was the
so give yourself a runway so yeah I was
like if after six months I'm not making
money and I'm not enjoying here then
I'll go and find a job elsewhere so six
months but then what I did what I did
was I made sure that I had enough money
saved before I started to know that I
wasn't under like extreme pressure from
like day one good advice
I've got I got given the advice of give
yourself at least three months personal
advice that I got so I had I had liked
to run the business cost and house
mortgage payments and everything like
live the same life pretty much like four
months yeah absolutely but then the
thing is as well that I realized is that
for most people when you've got if you
can drive your costs down you don't
actually need that much money to live on
a month-to-month basis so when you
actually realize what you need and what
it's like one fee it's like one place
yeah so it's different that's a great
thing when he was working at you study
at home overheads on mom you've already
got you've barely got any costs at all
so like what what were your what were
the first sort of tools it invested in
did you invest in like LinkedIn
recruiter straight away did you get a
decent CRM I invested in a like dirt
cheap CRM yeah cuz I invested in
LinkedIn recruiter light yeah and that
was it CRM no he's mad that in it that's
all you needed for yeah no no job boards
not nothing
yeah and I hammered referrals really so
you forgot a role about every single
candidate was like who else do you know
host you know who else do you know
I'll pay you I think it was like 250
quid if a place that burned so so so
those first couple months then like you
basically did you just sort of get
momentum through leveraging those 20
people that said you know I should load
you I'll help you out or whatever and
then he just saw snow balled and just
yeah it took some time it did take some
time because yeah I decided those
connections but and people who have
quite happy to have a conversation and
helped but it took some time to identify
the right kind of businesses that wanted
to work with getting that kinds of roles
on I was also I mean I wasn't so hard on
myself so I wasn't
I I gave myself light workouts but I
also if I wanted to go and have like her
there slightly longer lunch yeah I did
yeah didn't beat yourself up too much no
because I just again in my head I was
thinking because for me year one was
like am I going to enjoy here I wasn't
trying to like bill may close I just
wanted to like have enough yeah and see
River so I was I'm gonna enjoy it and
just see if I just so enjoy and that's
awesome and I actually met a client who
we sat down at such live like a good
like lunch with him and he said you one
of running your own business is so much
fun because and he was Spanish and he
was like I did mine in Barcelona he so I
just go out for like Friday afternoon or
two o'clock I just going man I'm just
going to the beach and he had the same
attitude but he said I'm telling you by
the time you get to year 3 & 4 it will
be very different
mm-hm and he's right yeah okay so so
then so then okay so year 1 then yeah
what did you do in year 1 then if
obviously the focus was am i enjoying
then someone joined the process the
journey working out the types of
business you in a work with building bit
momentum revenue where was you do
billions was like 60 60 grand yeah not
bad that doing that have your study is
it it literally paid for like we my
lifestyle pretty much stayed exactly the
same yeah because I worked at one of the
things I worked out was the fact that I
spend in 12 grand gross of my salary on
travel to get to work I just take 12
grand off yeah and then think about what
I actually need to have you have an own
month-to-month
how did you find working at home out of
a study if I'm thinking right now should
I go straight into again some sort of
co-working membership or whatever or
shadows smush I almost at like how did
you find that person because me
personally I can what I can work from
home but I I rent a flat in London so I
haven't got the freedom to create some
sort of nice working environment at home
yeah that does haven't got that
capability right now so yeah I couldn't
fit the four of me smash now phone calls
and these types of things in my living
room I around people personally yeah how
did you find out because I again I work
with quite a lot of and
one-man bands smaller businesses and
some of them do work in office but it's
sort of toying with the idea of them
maybe should I get something else to
reach back to they're about getting a
membership at where we rock on this
podcast but like how did you find that
first year of like just smash now in
your study room I loved it really
because as I was sat in shorts and
t-shirt like pretty much every single
day
oh god you were born for the digital
industry yeah and I worked in so I was
quite I was quite methodical about my my
day I'd get up I'd take the dog for a
nice walk already first yeah a good
routine but then working like I still do
but I work really well in bursts so I'd
be like literally like an hour an hour
and a half of just like intense focus
and work yeah and then just go and like
chill out for 15-20 minutes and just
like just do anything else
I didn't matter like put the washing on
or something like that something really
mundane yeah and then and then back to
it again but again because I wasn't
putting super super amounts of pressure
on myself I would start like 8:30 and
work to 5:30 yeah it's just not a lot
flexibility and yeah and I could get a
lot done in that time I could get a lot
done and it's just you right so you know
anybody else to manage or train or coach
or yeah I wasn't really too bothered
about getting a massive brand out there
just trying to find some roles and see
ya build some relationships I enough so
it's a year to them yeah well when on in
year two like so do you make your first
tie by then or was just doing the study
just to sort of set the scene so yeah -
I hired my wife Wow
yeah we didn't talk about that before
yeah really yeah yeah well she works
part-time so she was as I said teaching
she
six years amazing teacher like loved it
but was just working super crazy hours
yeah we were trying to have a family and
the whole thing just just wasn't working
really so we had a like we were going on
holiday to Cornwall her and I I need to
find a
I need someone to find me candidates um
science is like I've got too many
clients I can't manage this all by
myself I've got to find someone who's
gonna do this and she was like I can do
that like kind of joke like sorting yeah
I can source companies right yeah okay
yeah yeah and just drove along five hour
drive so I'm like joke yeah and I don't
you could actually do that yeah
no you could so we spend the rest of the
journey talking about it actually how it
would work like would you leave your job
would you eat that and she's she's a
smart person like running like running a
team etc like it's just resourcing
candidates that's all I need you to do
she's like yeah I'd love it
I just love the mundane like I just had
the lot I couldn't think of anything
worse but some people just love that so
I just love it I don't have any idea
what to do I was like just got to talk
to people that's what you do I can train
you just talk to people every day
and we'll work together so yeah so that
when was that conversation so that
conversation was end of year one I'll
really yeah the end of year one so
supply that when you got a decent man
that he had a decent amount of jobs on
and it yeah I could see so I'd got I was
enjoying it yeah um and again I store
wasn't like I desperately want to grow
and would create a massive brand or
anything I was just like well we're
growing we're winning more clients a
need resource to you know to help his
client so you see yeah
so that's the logical next logical step
and also like that first hire I was
talking to somebody about this today you
said there are other business with two
other directors and it's so much easier
if there's three of you because you got
differents gemston scare each other when
it's just you and that first height is
so important yeah because an idea to go
to hire somebody that you trust helps
with massively yeah massive lease and
you should be able to trust anyone and
no one you can trust more than you why
yeah hopefully so so ever since then
she's supported your business yeah so
awesome so like three months later she
handed the notice in at work we moved
into an office so we got an office in
Ashford where we are serviced office
literally like a two-person office you
know sat opposite each other um I just
felt like it was a good thing for us to
do because otherwise we'd be working
from home living at
I just thought well how'd you separate
it like the home light especially new
work on your wife right yeah you
separate
I was just having a comment yeah I get I
would I would one definitely want to do
that yeah and also like if in the
mornings that we were both leaving to go
to work even though we'd still be sat
opposite each other yeah yeah you've
left home to work yes good sort of set
to have it a lot right okay so this is
our intention this is why we're leaving
and when you get that lot right okay
this is what we need to do rather than
taking the nice little stroll in your
shorts to the studying oh right this is
what we need to do I totally get that
and I felt like I needed that as well at
that point because I loved the first
year it was like I I could I could get
too comfortable in that environment at I
needed to I needed I needed an office so
so we've got shared office yeah so then
yeah what then happened so I trained her
up
I got a sourcing candidates that was I
mean she was it's not difficult right so
yeah it's not difficult but and she was
really good at it
mmm we almost killed each other a couple
of times first yeah three or four months
yeah yeah yeah she because I've got a
certain way of doing things and
obviously I need her to work in a
certain way yeah and so and she's kind
of like the boss at home so when I'm
saying you needed it this way you know
she called me an [ __ ] and a few other
things so yeah I might say that yeah
okay
so you can see you to manage through
that but we got through that and then
honestly after that and all of our
friends and everyone we know like no
work wow you did that how can you but
and like after literally like two
arguments all good cracked on and and I
had a really good second year was it
just easier than for that whole year
yeah just a second here then we doubled
so we did like one month I would
actually do 130 really so awesome yeah
yeah yeah just like just literally in
the office again but we still kept
balance we weren't like that is not
really important to you yeah yeah it's
do you have you got children huh yeah
yeah we got one yeah one door to you was
Tuesday
yeah yeah so that's that's what worked
out as well it's been amazing has that
also helped them talking about balance
and personal relationships I mean you
bringing your wife into the business her
supporting you yeah that must have
helped I've had my own experiences this
way
I'm I'm in a relationship which she's a
person I want to be with long-term and
like what I've had to get better at is
communicating why I'm doing what I'm
doing and you thought what the drivers
are and these lots of things as opposed
to what are being sort of quite bad at
in the past is just sort of expecting
her to understand why I'm doing it and
like I have to stay late sometimes and
[ __ ] like that do you not I mean
so I guess her being involved and
understanding your world yeah how did
that help then you lied you know I mean
there must have been an actual
understanding there of like her
understanding what you've got to do the
input sometimes that's required to not I
mean then did that that must have helped
yeah massively cuz most people you don't
actually get to see you know your
partner might do another job but ya know
that they could be really high-powered
or really busy or whatever it is they're
doing yeah but you never actually get to
see them doing it day to day see you as
much as you can articulate the
challenges or the highs the lows yeah
until you see them and live them and
breathe and then you get it so yeah it
makes them it makes a big difference it
does make a big difference and she now
works two days a week
mmm it's awesome still no shouldn't she
does she could do like easily but I'm
she does finance ops accounting the
stuff that I'm assuming you don't want
to do yeah she's really good at and she
doesn't understand your business and the
sort of day-to-day yeah she gets it
completely so yes how do you think you
managed to do those what do you think
that some of the biggest contributing
factors you to doing those numbers and
year to because there's not bad that
right between Union you and your wife
140k not bad yeah I mean not bad those
figures you to have a much money to take
the business away but hundred okay yeah
their life that you live in the balance
or that's great right yeah absolutely
what would you think of some of the
things that contributed to that you
actually had to spend more time teaching
how to help you out what sourcing is
blah blah blah so could argue that you
were spread a bit more fin than you was
in year one right so what what do you
think contributed to that yeah there's
quite a few things one of the
interesting things about hiring somebody
with good working experience but no
recruitment experience and bring them
into your business is we're
who they are was I learnt quite a bit
from my wife in terms of stuff that she
did or approaches she was like why did
you do that that way what she's seen
question she challenged a lot of the
things which at first I hated but then
when I accepted it I was like so so
would it help to do this so like maybe
we could like structure like I don't
know like the calls that you do or why
we working with that client like it's
actually having somebody else saying
what what are you doing that for he's
got a complete open mind because she's
had no yeah yeah and like literally no
yeah and that was that was really
interesting but I am what we worked
through that we worked we were quite
picky about the the companies that we
worked with and making sure that they
they really understood what we were so
we were like we are a two-person
business yeah we weren't we didn't hide
away from the fact that were husband and
wife
yeah and if you're if you're looking to
work with a big agency that's got like
massive you know bandwidth in terms of
then great but that's not asked
we were really picky about the people
that we worked with and we were really
we invested so much time in building
kind of eight relationships so like the
quality of a quantity argument we just
like took it to the absolute extreme so
we handle eight qualification calls we
would spend so much time we go for
drinks with them win because we were
working on such a small pool of
opportunity really you wanted to we just
wanted to make sure that we nail
whatever yeah absolutely
out of interest what again thinking of
someone that's early on smaller business
I think I've been this from my own
experience sort of saying no when it's
your own business is that sort of
interesting experience I've found
personal sin no to a client because you
know it's not right or being picky as
you said yeah what what was sauce what
became their sort of non-negotiables for
you on this is a cramping on the work
with out of interest like what what did
the client have to say or what with the
things you were looking out for for you
to go you know what we're gonna we're
gonna obviously put resource to this job
in this company which makes me feel like
there's a good chance we make some money
out there first and foremost it was
about that initial interaction mmm so I
basically level did we get on yeah did I
like the person
mmm did they were they invested in what
we were doing mmm I mean from a number
from a practical level
yeah how many recruiters they working
with yeah do I believe I can fill the
role what kind of package they paying is
it competitive
what their expectations in terms of what
they can get for that so that yeah those
key criteria that most we all have but
more for me was does this person want to
meet see I was like we have to me so
anybody was like oh yeah I'll just give
you the brief over the phone is like no
no way
even less you meet with me I'm not
working with you and until we get on
like dog will wait on that meeting
thinking I can fill that role and
actually we because we worked with
smaller businesses I felt a bit more
invested in that company as well as I
want to fill that role as well yeah yeah
like that how I'm sure you've heard this
before I've definitely heard it before
like some some people quite sort of
unwilling to sort of really showcase how
small they are in the early stages you
know I mean yeah I think that's interest
in that because I think there's a lot of
power in sort of really owning what you
are and said look this is who we are
this is what you're getting if that's if
that's you and that's or aligned with
what you're about and great let's start
working together if it's not that's cool
yeah how did you did was that quite
empowering or like you know how did you
actually find that sort of resonate with
because a lot of people moment is
something oh I don't let them know it's
just me smash now my study yeah oh it's
me and my wife yeah some people may be
very reluctant say yeah you know I mean
because a lot of people sort of want to
talked about where they where they're
gonna be rather than where they are now
yeah it's interesting that I person
would be like I would personally have
just been
I'd rather be honest personally and just
say that this is where at and I think
particularly when you if if you're a
smaller business you start working with
smaller businesses that's actually
competitive advantage that look I'm
going through similar things you're
going through understand some of the
nuances of your world we're a small
business with granted you know I mean I
feel like that could actually become a
bit of an advantage but how did you
actually find being transparent and how
is actually how does that resonate with
the market yeah I mean at first I at
first I felt a bit uncomfortable
yeah but then a big then Oh a big driver
for me and still it is about
transparency yeah and about what we do
how we do it the way we operate as a
business it's just so important to me
so quite quickly I kind of just I guess
had a word of myself and just said no
like literally like going to these come
yes and if someone says like who else is
in your business my wife yeah we went to
client meetings together and in the back
of my head I was thinking this is we
placed a couple of count out the first
placement we did together we went out
for drinks for that candidate after and
this and the guy who in place was still
in contact with now and he was like
honestly said I completely bought into
you guys as a candidate because you
really invest in and I loved the fact so
then I was like well we're not going to
hide away from this there's no point in
doing that don't and and since then we
never have done so may feel a bit
uncomfortable the start but own there I
think that's great yeah it depends on
what environment you've come from as
well because I came from an environment
where it was quite to assert leasing
quite old-school in approaching them we
were suited and booted like clean shaven
black shoes shirt I kind of yeah me
where candidates face to face go through
like a very structured process which
worked at the time but when I set up I
was like I don't need to do that I don't
need to be like that I've got enough
experience I'll back myself yeah I don't
client says to me do you meet all of
your candidates or do you do I'm like no
I don't like yeah if you want me to I
can yeah but I don't need to and I
haven't got a massive resourcing team
behind me I've got me so before we go
into year three or four hmm all seems so
quite positive but obviously this sort
of always honest on this podcast so I
guess were there any sort of so you'd
spoken spoken a bit about your
relationship of your wife and how you
got better at that and communicated
these sorts of things but any any
particular challenges that you had to
really push for in this first two years
or was it yeah
what challenges came up there
you you one not really once once she
once I got billing yeah and look
confident momentum yeah yeah that was
fine
yeah you too yep definitely a little bit
more for us personal challenges was the
fact that yeah we cash flow and just
monitoring that cash flow was even with
a two-person business just making making
sure we managed that correctly because
we obviously both of our incomes were
directly linked to one business it it
kind of had to work yeah because there
was no other income coming from anywhere
else so yeah and we did like have like
one mega month and then like one where
we did like one deal I think we did we
did we do build every month but I'm yeah
just managing cash flow I'd also like
working out and she still something I've
not got quite right but working out what
to investing and what not to invest in
mmm that's interesting like yeah from a
tech from a job board perspective and
what tools to invest in yeah what what
tools and also looking back like
massively naive in terms of negotiating
with those so with the tools that yeah
we've different different providers so I
think that probably the challenging year
to is just naivety really have yeah and
also when you're at to thinking okay now
we're at to like when do we go to that
when how does that work what does that
look like mmm so it's a final question
right there nothing you sort of start
talking back there if if you were to
start the process again would you do
anything differently no really no I
wouldn't because everything I set out to
like get out of that process yeah I did
and that gave me the grounding to think
right now we're just going to start to
like crack on with this and see if we
can take this a little bit there mmm
make this a bit of a bigger entity no
because everything everything that
happened I learned from and I just
everything happens for a reason so I
just think wasn't just live and learn
say you're free and you're for then do
and you're in end-of-year for now or
going to you for we are
in tearful energy of yeah so you lot
well into your phone yeah it's a year
free then yeah
that's interested in so that when you
you'll see what was there what did you
and your wife look each other lot right
okay happy with what we did this year
yeah
learning's yeah experiences blah blah
blah what like where should we take this
was there a bit of a decision to be made
of light right should we just keep us
two or yeah like what how did you get to
the point of deciding to hire more
people or make it a larger entity as you
just saying well so my wife my wife fell
pregnant okay I'm just gonna lose my
resource here yeah that was a driver
then yeah that was a driver we got
approached by a guy who we knew from the
like from mark where we live who was in
recruitment working in legal work
crewmen in London he just wanted a bit
of advice around maybe not working in
London anymore yeah we met with him we
were like actually you've got some good
experience and maybe week that could be
an opportunity here yeah I'm and he was
like oh yeah actually that sounds really
cool um so we literally progressing and
hired him so I've been quite naturally
yeah so that was like two years ago how
did you how do you sell him that roll
out of interest because like me person
that is again thinking the questions I
get yeah a lot of people like
particularly I know you around the five
mark now but a lot of questions I get is
around sort of um in the five month want
to get to ten fifteen that's really
difficult 15-20 feet at its really
difficult but the common challenge
around that is yeah constantly having
people that you can offer your business
right yeah just how complete curiosity
like how do you send the opportunity his
drivers were I don't want to spit so
interesting in love his drivers were
very similar to my drivers when I set up
yeah I want to spend the rest of my life
commuting to London yeah I like
recruitment I think I'm good at it I'd
love to be based near to home yeah and
where we live there aren't many good
recruitment businesses there's a lot of
high street recruitment agencies there's
a couple of construct
recruitment agencies but there's nothing
which has the I say the quality and the
focus of maybe a London agency based
locally which was always a big intention
for me like I want to make sure that we
our standards are so high than much than
anybody else locally so if we do employ
people they can feel that they're coming
into a business there is like going to
really look after people and and
genuinely help them build a career so he
knew both of us anyway so that kind of
helped and again we were just really
open honest in said look this is like
jinny my wife she's gonna be going like
I have on maternity leave and we don't
really know what that's gonna look like
yet but and I've got clients you've got
some experience like we could definitely
make this work and at that point we were
like we want we want to start growing
and hiring a few more people again still
wasn't like a rock-solid plan of yeah
yeah we want to scale to new that's into
it like I just yeah I just knew that I
wouldn't be happy just working as like
one or two of us yes I I've got more
Drive there's more by that point I kind
of got through that whole like post
London slump if you like yes Ryan of
like and I was like actually no no
there's a bit like I need to I want to
do something and and create something I
think so yeah it wasn't it wasn't I
don't think it was a difficult sell fair
enough yeah you knew you knew what his
motivations were they're very the
similar to you yeah yeah well we may not
be able to offer you everything like
right now in terms of what you've been
used to but that's what we definitely
can offer you in that resonated yeah
okay that's interesting so and then so
year free then is that what did you then
get and a couple of other people when
involved and or was it the sort of going
into this year now where you hide we
hide we hide Callum I just realized year
four we've come to the end of our year
four we go we're into year five yeah so
yeah Cal enjoins then Ginny went on
maternity leave there's just Callum and
I yeah literally boaters doing 360 roles
which is working pretty fine
we then hired a junior consultant we
have the model for us is when you hire
somebody if they're inexperienced or
no experience they come in as just a
kind of resource of the 180 yeah yeah
and so we hired somebody in the end of
2018 yeah he had some recruitment
experience she unfortunately just she
didn't work out had some kind of some
health issues and stuff that just yeah
just didn't work and then we were kind
of back to - yeah and then and then
Ginny came back in working two days a
week but in a non resorting role and
then last year we hired two more junior
consultants and they stood that we had
to in the summer one of the two is still
there and then we hired another guy just
before Christmas nice so awesome yeah
and then talk to me talk and share a bit
about cuz obviously just from the
contacts that I had before maybe what's
been the evolution of this or focus then
and this little niche aspect because he
started in digital right which as you've
already shared with us where you did
cultivate and build some sort of
relationships with some people yeah how
and then all she started this - again
second years still in digital yep and
then how is it how is that how is that
evolved so coming as the last two years
we started working with three primarily
my network and contacts we started
working with some smaller sass tech
companies yeah and and helping them hire
and grow from scratch their their sales
team and their marketing team and so
over the course of 2018 just like to
work with a few more companies and that
space is really interesting by some
really cool companies different ideas
they did really love the fact that we
were a small company because we would
invest a lot of time in them and give
them probably a much probably a lot more
than maybe a bigger agency would into
their service and time spent even
helping them to write things like the
job specs et cetera and then coming into
last year 2019 which we just kind of
pivoted the business really and just
like look digital this was very very
there's a lot of big players in the
digital
say yeah it's saturated yeah and and and
we didn't we looked at our network and
actually realize that we didn't have a
strong network I didn't have a strong
network necessary in digital I did have
a strong network in SAS instead I just
built through relationships and contacts
and getting and placing real emphasis on
building that that network so yeah we
started last year we came into last year
and just let everything we do from now
on is this gonna be more and more
focused towards this let's go for it in
2019 and start to so how does that have
an impact it's it's been great because
it's it gives very clear focus
internally around the kind of profiles
of companies that were going after and
how helpful is that like what how why is
that helpful
tell focus I think it's personally
really helpful because now I feel that
as we grow the business I it's very
clear from the top down what our
marketplace is and who we work with and
why we work with them and why we add
value to them and so because I'm so
clear on that people who come into the
business immediately in London that are
aligned with that and they believe in it
and they enjoy it like we it's it's a
really enjoyable space to work in we we
come across lots of really interesting
businesses and it's just it's just
evolved from that did did part of you
think all that can done sort of turning
my back on quite a bit of business here
potentially or yeah but we looked at we
looked at clients that we worked with he
didn't fall into that category and
realized that some of those bigger
brands that we were recruiting for we
didn't have the best terms of business
yeah our conversion rate wasn't as good
but yes their process wasn't as good
loads of factors and actually just
walking like moving away from the who
Somerton going into organizations where
they didn't have any recruitment
partners and you could create that
impact that partnership that environment
yourself from scratch was really
liberating because mmm there wasn't any
of the hang-ups of like working on a PSL
or yeah not being able to speak to the
decision-maker which we were speaking
directly to the founders of businesses
I did this because I think the reason I
was asking I think a lot of people can
be a bit worried about all I might be
missing out on a lot of stuff here and
these things but I think that's a great
exercise to actually do because you can
very easily fall into the trap of just
doing what you've always done you know I
mean so whenever you're doing your
interview or whatever I think that
sounds like a really practical it sounds
simple but if you haven't looked at the
last year what how many businesses are
you place with what I actually try and
think about measuring the relationships
with those businesses or the terms what
those things and then actually well
actually yeah these businesses over here
when we work with them that we actually
have a better relations which then gives
you there's more data to back up why you
should put we eggs in that basket yeah
and I think I just think that's that's
such a valuable and practical exercise
at the same time I think the people that
I speak to you'd like just actually
having a real niche and focus is so
powerful yeah because like on this or
face of you my thing yeah I'm not sure
there's enough here but really in
reality when you really know it's the
whole sort of inch wide mile deep
fingers in that and I think I says well
I've used in cliche but James Osborne's
today yeah I think this it's obviously
it sounds really it's just I just think
that there's so much power on that so if
you're thinking of what we should be
focusing on even as just working as a
recruiter light are you actually do you
need to be working on all those roles
right now yeah don't know yeah you used
to be working on five particular job
titles lots of things where you could
become like that absolute expert and
go-to person for that yeah 100 actually
owner I think it's really powerful I've
had quite a few recent conversations
with people that start their own
recruitment business and typically in
the when they've been employed they've
done quite a variety but and then
they've actually really focused on like
to a free particular specific skill set
double down on that and that's actually
enabling to focus when at the beginning
can be like [ __ ] what the hell do I do
no I mean yeah that's really interesting
that you've gone through that yeah I
think that I think that so many people
in all injured in recruitment I was
always looking forward forward forward
forward what we doing next month next
quarter next yeah being more reflective
over what you've done previously and
being brutally honest about first of all
I have I enjoyed working with those
companies
yeah you got you got you enjoy it like
yeah it's unfortunate but you have to
look and and just being able to and also
not being not being afraid to give er a
business and change it mm-hmm
no matter what the company name is or
what your marketing done yeah it doesn't
matter like work on staff and work with
brands and work in a sector that you
enjoy and that you believe there's great
opportunity in and that you can I value
in and if that's different what it was
two years ago then then so be it
yeah so how did this how did this impact
revenue-wise my room because there
couldn't be some challenges there right
you're talking about cash flow Ellie I
just you to managing that yeah how did
that sort of you hired you hired one
person had another person didn't quite
work out then I'll see hard two people
one person stayed like how how was that
how was that sort of experience in
impact in revenue yes definitely I think
hiring somebody and retaining that
person so Callum our first hire he's
still with the business yeah investing
in him and being I don't think
personally that if you even if someone
and that someone's got a lot of
experience if they've got a little bit
of recruitment experience or sales
experience in order for them to start
billing certain numbers that really
change your business is probably two
years there are exceptions that rule but
say GG typically do you typically give
them that sort of runway is that typical
your mindset when you're making a high
yeah yeah yeah yeah which is a risky
move but but I I think that when you're
hiring
if you hire on on values as much as you
do anything else some people who have
the right intentions and work work ethic
can't speak and energy yeah and they
want to learn and they for me violent
somebody comes in in the morning just
brings great energy day and that sort of
stage of a business yeah yeah massively
impacts on your environment it is one
person it's just not bringing in
American grain you've got to have that
and so if they're doing that then I of
course I care if they build but as long
as they're developing and learning then
year one is
I'm not expecting to see a dramatic like
uplift in revenue yeah of course if we
do it'd be great but yeah I guess the
answer to your question what are we
saying we're starting to see a positive
impact in terms of revenue raising but I
still think we're probably six months
away from the scene like a real sort of
field yeah so but that's been your
mindset there that's interesting yeah
and then and a big contributing factor
for you sort of deciding not sure
actually obviously I've got the
mentality of harness person they're
gonna be a year plus on in terms of the
actual return Ben business-wise whatever
BER you're looking for energy work ethic
volume learning often right questions
yeah and then I'm a [ __ ] yeah some of
the if you're not getting some of those
things you've got a sort of relying
you're sort of gonna stinks and startin
not sure if this is the right Maya yeah
100%
I just as long as someone's
demonstrating the right the right
attributes and and the right habits yeah
and they're their present and when
they're there they're working and
they're engaged and they're learning and
they're curious and they're investing
their own you know their own energy and
then that to me is I I think you can you
can teach anyone how to do this job you
know as long as they've got that desire
to and I do yeah you don't have to be
what we I used to hire a lot on
intellects okay well Oh what in terms of
what they do the union that yeah really
why I don't know you have some good
experiences with people that have
experiences or searches of hiring smart
people and there's no doubt if you can
find someone who's a smart person who's
also got all of those other attributes
there and be dense and they're probably
going to be pretty good but equally
there's a lot of really good people who
burn a lot don't have that and have like
the right all the other stuff and
actually they're going to be really
successful hey April turn as one he
that's fair enough mate so biggest
biggest well so what was obviously gone
into five year five now what where are
you revenue wise year for and year for
as you do so we did just shot three
hundred nice and that's between that was
pretty much what between lot free for
yeah like three free and about is that
no is it's good it needs it's good for
we're out last year was a big year for
us in terms of direction and yes I feel
that you do probably feel that you've
really got this sort of foundation yeah
nucleus now it's a big goes this year
over a lot bigger yeah yeah we got big
growth goals you want to hire three more
people and then consultants was on a
higher marketing person as well really
um yeah in in key for so and then what
you aiming for like women break the
million mark this year yeah from 300 why
not 500 yeah okay so I think we did
another 200,000 this year with a team of
by the end of the year be team of eight
then next year will be set up to get
towards those kind of numbers why do you
why I mean that typically a real quitman
business owner investing in a permanent
marketing employee where's that
motivation coming from advice yeah
advice so yeah we last year became part
of the recruitment network and have
really utilized that network a lot that
was that's helped us a lot in terms of
formulating our strategy in our plan
it's also given me a renewed focus and a
real clear direction of where I want to
go and take the business ok and also
understanding what are those key and
critical hires that are going to help us
get there yeah and yeah hiring hiring a
marketing person I think there's only so
many things that I can do in a day or a
week and you can try and get somebody
else in your business to do those things
so yeah my wife did some marketing stuff
for us for a bit but she doesn't really
enjoy it and it's not something that
she's amazing at mmm so and you can try
and get your consultants to do their
bits and
which definitely helps but I think that
in this day and age in recruitment you
have to be producing lots and lots of
really interesting relevant content that
is engaging and drives in yeah
interaction with your business and
actually even a what will be an a person
business hiring somebody who might not
be full-time at your part-time behind
he's gonna but you want something that's
got a dedicated focus resource on that
experience and actually enjoys it yeah
and and has like a really interesting
tone of voice I don't want somebody
who's a I don't know you what
something's come from recruitment I want
someone who's come from something
completely different and really creative
and just can come to our business and
create stuff that is different and
unique yeah so yeah here a lot little
cream and business own and say that but
then when push comes with shelves their
[ __ ] their pants when they come up with
all different ideas yeah but have you
seen my LinkedIn video yeah definitely
that was sort of part of obviously why I
was interested get your thoughts cuz you
were clearly someone that is willing to
be vulnerable and and yeah made do
things that made people may have got all
my god what is he up to quite a few
people have said like what are you doing
dancing like yeah you're a 38 year old
man like that dance you know the thing
I'm like but I won I genuinely find it
it's just fun yeah - we get amazing
response from it we just get like really
cool levels of engagement and candidates
and clients people talk about it so
again like going down that theory of not
wanting to be - like not trying to be
something that you're not yeah exactly
about that's kind of what we're about
and why not do stuff that he's really
really different I love that biggest
challenges over the last two years would
you say spoken about a lot of good
things learnings folks in your business
yeah any any key things that come to
mind when I say year for your free
challenges consistency of billing and
for you personally or just well
throughout actually yeah yeah personally
um throughout for me personally managing
the various
once you start to have like two other
people you are manage and do your own
billing and do the other things that
just seems to take up time like business
yet spread thin so being able to get
back to doing what primarily you enjoy
doing mm-hmm it's challenging and
prioritizing that his is sometimes hard
yeah so what does a typical day like for
you are you quite rigid yeah I am yeah
would a good day plan that life so I get
in 7 737 here 5 most days I the first
thing I do typically is just look at my
look at my diary make sure that I'm
planned make sure I've got like space my
diary for various tasks you know I'm
quite weeks a week I have certain things
that I do the same time every single
week so it might be like a sticky list
of things that I just like longer term
objectives and every week I'll do one
thing on that list you break it down see
I break it down and pretty specifically
so like to get in before everyone just
so I've got a bit of time to do that
first 45 minutes before anyone gets in I
try and do as much client stuff as I can
especially at the moment cuz we decide
somebody's just started yeah he needs a
lot of training in support so it's doing
that then come in then then I'll work
with one of the people in the teams at
the moment junior person doing just was
all seeing training etc but I'm quite
methodical about I get I get really like
annoyed if I don't if I don't stick to a
diary you know I'll just do I on the
same I'm bad for that I need to but yeah
I always the most productive days I have
is like our slots like focus on that and
then yeah and I'll tell you get that
yeah I have to be organized I I get like
yeah I just I know that if I'm
disorganized
I just don't know and in a smaller
business I'm thinking of the business
that I was in twelve person business at
darling that's only the business still
speak some now a lot and nothing I will
see when you're that sort of size it is
hard to light you will get pulled pillar
to post light lloyd just had this chart
what do you think what should i do like
you're the person obviously that all the
time yeah you know I mean it's like when
you're when you need to be methodical
just because it's like right I'm doing
this because it's gonna enable me to
have the best possible output this day
how how can you manage that when light
you know I mean it's like just me you
free other people sit in an office to be
like look I'll wear I will help but I
need to just crack on with this light
you know I mean yeah so I'm still
learning that I started doing it in the
last year and I've started doing into
this year is that I'll take myself out
the office because we're in a serviced
office there's always a spare office
rooms yeah
so I I'll give myself like an hour tried
to do an hour a day hmm
out the office just by myself yeah and I
get so much done then that then when I
come back into the office if there's a
load of questions I can be like yeah let
me answer all those yes now alarm
there's also the danger I think that you
have if you're always there people will
always ask you the question yeah
definitely so just taking yourself out
the situation he says might find out
themselves or discuss it
I'm massive on the guy we hired just
before Christmas I'm not the only one
doing his training
I've got Lucy in our team he's only been
with us for six months yeah she's doing
some of his training what come doing
some of his training just so that he
gets a rounded yeah kind of an
unexpected yeah it doesn't and from me
as well it's like the same voice talking
all the time yeah no answer
it's just interesting to hear about that
so what what I'd love to just ask you is
so I've got may or may not have seen it
have a event coming up and live podcast
event and it's all about cultivating
resilience and going the distance and
recruiting them so a couple of questions
just focused on resilience I'd love to
just get your thoughts on okay and then
I can ask you what you're excited about
and finished this episode say okay first
question
what does resilience in recruitment mean
to you
what does it mean to me
I think resilience in recruitment is as
a quality is is everything naturally mmm
I think is absolutely everything we're
talking about like attributes earlier
yeah I won't do I look for in those
people that we hire and what day if
you're not a resilient character in
recruitment you just won't make it it's
as simple as that
yeah I'd you look out for that in people
typically I think you have to when when
interviewing you have to understand what
what hardships have they gone through
like how and they had like tough times
in their life and dig down into those
and if I think about some people that
I've hired in the past you haven't
worked out they were quite fortunate to
live quite charmed lives where nothing
had ever really gone wrong sure and that
everything had been kind of like quite
plain sailing and you know they never
had to deal with rejection or more like
massive stuff just going wrong yeah so
but then I look at those people I think
that in those first few months you can
tell because it stuff happens right like
it happens every single day
and most people the first time like a
candidate doesn't show up for their
final interview or you have a blowout or
something happens the first one that
happens is is [ __ ] for everyone you know
yeah it is but I think and you accept
that and you just my advice always is
when it happens is just if go home but
even if it's early just go home because
you're clearly like just you've had
enough of today you know go home get
annoyed about it but when you come back
in tomorrow
do not show an ounce of new day a new
day and and if you can do that then that
like just like bare-bones resilience
that that's what it's about is about
picking yourself up from you learn most
about people when when they fail do they
pick themselves up dust themselves off
and just go again yeah
or do they dwell on it and if they dwell
on it and they're the type
character that dwells on it then you
just didn't know the recruitment is not
for you like that next question
how has the importance or need for
resilience changed as an industry has
evolved it's a good question comes to
mind
well it's interesting because I think
the recruitment is entry might in my
opinion and my perspective that
recruitment is an industry in terms of
quality now compared to when I started I
genuinely believe that the quality and
the attention and the and determination
of recruitment founders to provide a
quality service is much better than it
was when I started yeah so the reason
that's important for resilience is the
fact that when I started we had a lot
more there was a lot more rejection that
happened because I think that maybe the
quality over quantity but debate wasn't
quite right within our business there's
not as much that goes wrong mm-hmm so we
so we put a lot of processes in place to
ensure that we don't have to be as
resilient or deal with failure as much
as maybe we've done in the past nothing
time so I think how has it changed I
think that I do think generally younger
the the younger generation maybe this is
a very blanket statement but being
resilient is not something that's
necessarily taught as a as a quality
like it's not it's not something that
they think about or have to consider and
certainly if you ask people who were
much older than me who've been through
much tougher time yes yeah wars or
whatever they are like the needs to go
through hardship and going through hard
times builds a resilience but if you've
always lived in an environment in the
world which is really cozy then if
you're not had to be exposed to much
that's led you to be resilient then how
can you really ya know what it means so
I have so I think it's really sometimes
it's really hard actually to to meet
young people and we do hire young people
and say to them you like what's gone
wrong in your life cuz like the chances
are that not much really hey you know
it's also the four of having something
going wrong is like petrifying tonight I
mean and today's work because everything
that's what perceptions everything needs
to be rosy and perfect or everyone needs
to see it as your life is perfect and
going great you know I mean yeah there's
there's definitely like less of a yeah
like that that feeling there like taking
yourself out of your comfort zone and
doing something that makes you feel
vulnerable yeah it's something that
people more than ever hate yeah actually
if you're building a career in
recruitment then you'll be in there's a
lot of times you'll be vulnerable yeah a
lot a lot and the start especially your
beginning where you're gonna interview
loads of people and you're going to try
and sound like an expert and you're not
yeah a serial you are experts you're
gonna meet with clients and if you think
about every kind of step of the
recruitment journey there's if you
you're going to feel vulnerable at every
single point yeah you do and everyone
feels it but you have to find the inner
determination to do that yeah it's
difficult if you haven't had to yeah
definitely
yeah I've never really thought about it
that way but it's yeah it's challenging
mmm so what what can people do
themselves to either obviously maybe
your experiences in others but what's up
welcome what are your thoughts on what
can people do themselves to instill
resilience in in them or their teams I
think you've got heard you've got to
push people to do stuff that what we
just said you've got to push people to
do stuff that makes them feel vulnerable
and puts it puts out there knowing that
it won't always go to plan yeah
and that actually may are crystal clear
Lloyd you might have a [ __ ] day today
yeah like this maybe yeah
I want you to do this and there's no
guarantee that it's gonna be successful
it's gonna make you feel really really
weird yeah um and you're probably
thinking I shouldn't do this
and if it doesn't go if it doesn't go to
plan like you're gonna have to be able
to disco that's cool yeah it's an
experience I don't from it I'm moving on
from yeah I think you've got to push
people to do it because otherwise you
won't realize the potential I think in
especially in the recruitment world now
that we live in
yeah net networking building
relationships putting yourself out there
is more important than it has ever been
I believe yeah and you've got to be a
resilient character to to get through
that this is just really sort of
communicate that things could go wrong
and you experience setbacks and just
make sure that's that's clear from from
early on yeah also helping coach people
through that yes I understand
I'm massive I asked who my team how you
feeling
yeah good question how you feeling you
feeling okay you feeling good today you
sure you okay I think they get really
annoyed at me asking it but I think it's
so important to understand how people's
feeling how does that such a great
question how does that make you feel I
think that maybe they a lot I don't know
like for me it's really important
because I want someone to feel good and
enjoy what they're doing if you just
focus on the numbers all the time and
people are doing a load of stuff that
they don't enjoy doing it makes them
feel crap and they're trying to be
resilient but they don't sometimes don't
even understand why they're feeling that
way yeah absolutely love that mate I
think in today's day and world as well
all I put my personal thing on that or
like that is like I know and you can't
answer we're busy how are you feeling on
how you do and you go yeah busy okay
what the [ __ ] do you mean like yeah yeah
Vala dance that's not how you feeling
yeah yeah no I think that that's the
change because typically it's like you
know how things are things going how are
you doing yeah but how you feeling is
just a way it's a slight change it's way
more powerful question cuz it's like no
no like how you actually feel in like
are you feeling good you feeling
positive or rather than the typical
light yeah how are you doing like how
you're getting on today or whatever yeah
I'm still not happy about what happened
yesterday okay yeah that's a great
question I just hate the rust such a
just easy to use word busy it's just I
use I hate it just this like would what
do you mean yeah hey Lord you're busy
yeah what you mean like give me some
more context I'm asking you a question
here
yeah but thinking the danger that also
is light it's very easy if you like what
if something is isn't right yeah busy
I'm busy yeah like do you know I mean
it's quite easy comfort blanket just be
like yeah I'm busy you know I mean yeah
because also people don't necessarily
like sauntering that question yeah and
they're definitely not how often do you
get asked that yeah you feeling okay
mm-hmm
so before I she the final question
walking what are you excited about Lloyd
what's going on your world so also you
know I sort of mentioned it literally
earlier but decided you're gonna have a
real focus on the sort of people that
you've been serving and helping but what
what you excited about in 2020 and
Beyond for your recruitment business
immediately what we excited about so
excited about renaming and rebranding
the business always exciting stuff like
that yeah talent digital doesn't truly
reflect the nature of what we do now the
nature of what we do now is Tekken SAS
and it sales and marketing so we're
doing some work at the moment to try and
come up with a name that really reflects
what we do about which and then and then
do some branding around that we're gonna
do an event at the end of quarter to
hopefully which is in line with that
we're kind of like launch of our new
brand but also we're gonna get a load of
our clients see and just people who want
to come you want to understand more
about the start-up scale-up community
and most challenges and things that
happen in that so that's that's a big
focus for us hire more people and yeah I
just think get probably not that we
haven't been serious but get really
serious about what growth plans and and
yeah just how you hopefully hire some
amazing people you know it's amazing I
think I've been meaning to just I think
that's amazing man I think what I love
about your story and I'll cut I can't
remember it sort of well read this or
listen to it but it's just really
resonated with me in this but where I'm
at in my journal I think it's evident
with sort of yours is like like where
you start isn't wave finish yeah you
know so it's just so important to
remember that yeah wherever you are
lighting right now in your career in
your business journey or what
like where you start is not way
necessary under a lot of fing again to
ran them off you started at home yeah I
want to work closer to family yeah
Ashford I'm in a time in my shorts and
like now it's like yeah quick you can
have an event we're gonna grow a
business do you not I mean yeah it's
like where you start wherever you start
doesn't mean where you can end up and I
just absolutely love that because that
there's just so much do not I mean I
just think that's such a great thing to
remember yeah like a massive buzz for me
now is where we live in in Ashford
there's a huge amount of development
going on down there we're really near to
London it's well-connected etc etc like
big thing for me now is I want people to
talk about us as an employer of choices
in life you should go and work in that
business cuz it's really cool yeah yeah
love that last question yeah so you can
answer this with a phrase sentence or
word whatever comes to mind
yeah the question is if Lloyds could
communicate to every single recruiter
out there business owner they'd listen
to your advice said take on your advice
had implemented to my yeah what would
you say to the people oh that's a good
question I would say what I say I would
say have a plan don't be scared to
completely rip up that plan don't be too
hard on yourself be realistic about what
you actually can achieve and and what
you want to get out of what you're doing
and and yeah just just I think
intentions like just be clear on what
your intention is and your intention
doesn't have to be that you're gonna
grow a billion-dollar business your
intention can be to just have a
wonderful life and that's cool amazing
Lord it's been a pleasure thank you very
much